bonjour à tous nous poursuivons nos
découvertes gastronomiques et
aujourd'hui nous sommes venus rencontrer
le chef Thomas Parnaud à Chartres il
travaille les céréales anciennes dans
son restaurant étoilé le Georges nous
sommes justement devant suivez-moi
[Musique]
bonjour Thomas Arnaud merci de nous
accueillir dans votre établissement
ça fait 5 ans que vous êtes à la tête du
genre et vous venez tout juste d'obtenir
un écho label trois macarons
racontez-nous un peu en quoi ça consiste
c'est ça et on a engagé la chose il y a
maintenant plusieurs mois ou ecotables
est une plateforme qui met en avant tout
ce que l'on fait finalement depuis 5 ans
le travail de de
majoritairement plus de 90% d'acteurs
locaux artisans locaux et qui ont
travaillé en direct majoritairement en
agriculture biologique ou raisonnée donc
c'est un sujet assez vaste finalement
qui englobe différents critères assez
spécifiques pour l'obtention de cette
note de 3 macarons etc
on est ici dans la bosse dans le grenier
de la France et c'est quelque chose qui
vous a qui vous intéresse dans votre
cuisine de travailler les céréales
notamment les variétés anciennes comment
ça se traduit dans un plat la créativité
elle est totalement après j'ai envie de
dire presque un feeling là-dessus donc
on peut la retrouver soufflée en tuile
en gruau donc voilà c'est
différente façon diverses et variées de
travailler la céréales alors justement
vous travaillez en lien avec un minotier
avec qui vous avez créé un pain
signature on va tout de suite regarder
ce reportage chez Alexandre Viron
réalisé avec Charlie Krief et Laurence
Borie
ils font de la farine depuis 7
générations au cœur de la Beauce grenier
de la France le Moulin de Viron est une
institution des farines bio d'excellence
issues de blédard et loirs de quoi
convaincre Thomas Parnaud de collaborer
avec ce minotier
différentes céréales il y avait le
Corazon qui est ton produit préféré mais
est-ce que tu as fait quelque chose avec
l'engrin parce que ça franchement et un
super produit Thomas Pinault s'est
appuyé sur le savoir-faire d'Alexandre
Viron pour créer un pain signature pour
son restaurant étoilé deux jours de
création les mains dans la pâte ont été
nécessaires pour élaborer ce pain unique
le pétrissement de la pâte moi je vais
le faire vous vous allez le faire
Alexandre va le faire et au final on
aura pas le même pas à la fin c'est il y
a vraiment l'intention que l'on est dans
dans la pâte au delà du grammage ou de
la des choix de blé enfin voilà c'est
vraiment un travail très complet et qui
est
hyper enrichissant
l'assemblage a été créé à partir de
variétés anciennes de blé dont certaines
ont particulièrement retenu l'attention
de Thomas Parnaud pour les dénicher
Alexandre Viron a lui-même cultivé plus
de 120 variétés de blé le Coran l'une
des plus anciennes compose ce pain
signature
et lorsque l'on a présenté à Thomas les
différentes variétés c'est là où il est
tombé en arrêt sur le corps Azan c'est
là où l'engrin lui a permis de voir des
choses un petit peu originales en les
faisant souffler en les mettant en forme
de tuiles ou autres produits mais c'est
à l'origine c'était de choisir des
variétés anciennes et surtout comprendre
pourquoi il était intéressant ou non de
les faire revivre
au George ce pain signature à base de
Corazon est présenté aux côtés du rétro
d'or le pain emblématique de la
minoterie vironde nous sommes de retour
dans les cuisines du genre et Thomas
Pinault vous allez nous préparer un oeuf
à la chartre on va mettre nos cornichons
alors qu'on a juste juste haché donc ça
ça va venir un petit peu condimenter
notre œuf
là ici on a notre bouillon de volaille
qu'on a légèrement gélifié on va en
mettre tout autour
ensuite on va prendre notre
rémoulade et là on va venir
juste pocher
5 points là on va passer à une autre
étape qui va être de mettre notre œuf
donc là on est sur un œuf bio Célestine
qu'on a toujours en Eure-et-Loir cette
oeuf on l'a fait mollet et on est venu
le glacer d'un jus de veau à l'estragon
donc cette oeuf on va le prendre
délicatement
et on va venir le disposer au milieu
de
c'est super
de notre assiette donc là ce petit
gâteau très aéré de d'herbe en fait donc
de persil de cerfeuil d'estragon ensuite
on va mettre le côté céréales donc là on
est sur des toasts Melba ce sont des
fines tranches coupées qu'on va ensuite
badigeonner d'un beurre clarifié là ici
on a une petite tuile de ciboulette
je rajoute une petite fleur de sel
là c'est la touche finale on va venir
dans ce très beau contenant le refermer
et voici donc une des entrées finalement
phare une des entrées du restaurant Le
Georges donc l’œuf à l'achat superbe
merci beaucoup en tout cas de nous avoir
fait redécouvrir cette incontournable de
la gastronomie française demain notre
page était continue on sera avec un
autre chef étoilé à Blois Christophe et